yes a monkey apocalypse let's talk about
this it's not just about the monkeys
this segment we're gonna be talking
about the chaos that ensues following
the global pandemic the lack of tourism
is causing trouble this is how Planet of
the Apes starts out look at us as
coronavirus slams Thailand tourism
monkeys brawl in the street they're
pretty cute Lagoon I love this I mean I
feel bad I feel bad for the monkeys I
feel bad for the locals man but hold on
that soothes the monkeys for those
wondering think about this chaos though
hold on for a second hold on yeah for
those that for those that are just
listening there is what is hundred plus
200 there's got to be like my least 100
things baboons yeah well they're mummies
no they're literally monkeys what are
they they're called lop buri monkeys all
right series of them so this is why they
say don't feed the monkeys there were
bound to be plenty of unpredictable
consequences as a result of the corona
virus outbreak but a gang war between
rival packs of monkeys in the streets of
Thailand according to the Bangkok Post
that's exactly what happened in the
province of lop buri this week as
hundreds of monkeys brawled over scraps
of food apparently tourists who normally
keep them well-fed are staying away due
to the krona virus outbreak watch the
clip actually yeah
there's so many of them these have-nots
dude look at this dude I'd be freaking
out well the locals like they don't they
like let them all run around so it's
like they're comfortable around humans
yeah so right now what do you do if
you're listening it's literally just a
bunch of monkeys running through the
streets what I want to know hundreds
when the monkeys find out there's food
inside the houses yeah dude that's the
next video that we're gonna the next
clip is gonna come to this oh man
they're seriously brawling
[Applause]
and it's over and they're all dispersing
it does sound like birds isn't it now
let me tell you something scary that's
nuts
what do you think is gonna happen here
what do you think Anna happen in the in
the states in the cities mm-hmm when
food dries up it's gonna be people
there's gonna be people doing literally
the same thing yeah man absolutely the
difference I I was I was talking to
people when I lived in New York and why
I didn't want to live there anymore as
political tensions start getting crazy
yeah
and I'm just like it's just not a smart
place to be because basically one of the
reasons I want to get out was because
someone planted a bunch of bombs
straight up when he was in Manhattan a
couple years ago now it's been I think 2
or 3 years maybe I was at my place I had
moved I moved out of I went to the
Jersey side to Union City okay and I was
trying to get away from you know just
like the high rent I wasn't in sale that
often yeah and then I was at home and I
saw it on Twitter a bunch of bombs that
were planted and on the Jersey side and
I think it was in Jersey City oh and in
in Manhattan and they went off and so I
was like dude there's literally no
reason for me to just be in this really
expensive place I'm gonna get out I'm
not saying the world is gonna end or
anything that I don't think so I don't
prep or anything you know I don't even
have a gun but I'll tell you this man
you can choose to prep and go off into
the wilderness and nothing might happen
that's fine or or and also you can do
nothing but the very least don't be in
these big like major urban condensed
dense places where when when coronavirus
breaks out everyone gets it because you
live in you live in a building with like
200 people yeah that all hit the same
elevator button exactly and then you got
that one a hole that's licking the
button that happened but that's not
really people watching a dude literally
nor do you like licked his hand rights
are rubbing the elevator buttons yeah
and then you touch it you look at these
monkeys and we laugh ha ha so funny
you have no idea I wouldn't want to be
anywhere near that no but I mean like I
was watching this video it's like people
are sharing it laughing like wow it's so
great look at the monkeys fight yeah
you're a monkey too bro yeah like we're
humans were primates there's gonna
we don't have food exactly and people
are gonna be boxing each other in the
streets fighting over that last can of
beans in the Walmart parking lot this is
this is what's messed up man I told
everybody you know I said you do not
want to be that person fighting over a
can of beans with Agnes in the parking
lot of a Walmart because there's no food
left so go out and make sure you buy
stuff and of course I got people
laughing so no to who we're so smart
we're looking to blow anything and now
not what's going on panic buying yep so
here's the thing I think it's funny we
can show you this monkey video but I
think it's it's a real example of you
know everyone's laughing saying haha
it's Planet of the Apes they laugh -
we're so funny and I get it is kind of
funny like all admit it but then we see
this look at this panic buyers empty
shelves across the country and cops tell
people to stop calling 9-1-1 overline
skipper's as thousands flood into stores
over coronavirus people are calling
9-1-1 from yattaman cutting the line yup
but what do you think comes next man
look at this this is Trader Joe's in
Manhattan nuts somebody posted clips the
entire no no no no that's what Trader
Joe's looks every single time in
Manhattan so that's that's on that's the
DEF give that out here right yeah I did
someone send me a picture from Costco
and they said the line went all the way
to the bag was stored now that's a big
store Costco somebody somebody posted
videos from Trader Joe's this is not
normal dude there's there's a line to
get into Trader Joe's yes
normally my I I had a friend man live
I'm just saying I had a friend who lived
right nice to Trader Joe's in Manhattan
and we still go there every weekend to
get to get drinks and stuff yes there
was a line it was not this this is nuts
yes I'm seeing absolutely no and
Brooklyn wasn't crazy like there would
be that there would be a major line in
Brooklyn but you could still walk in the
building and grab stuff and go buy it
yeah sure the point is right now people
aren't freaking out because there is
still some food yeah but dude Manhattan
is the last place you want to be and
where does all this stuff come from what
the food America good so it's America so
we do grow a decent amount of food here
but a lot of it is California yeah yeah
I'm sorry what's gonna happen it's gonna
be funny California in the event of a
major catastrophe
secede yep yeah I mean I joke about it
like there
there are people who are dead series
about California seceding yeah but when
there's no more food they're gonna be
like bye-bye but here's the fine here's
a funny part
it's not gonna be San Francisco in LA
it's gonna be Eastern California telling
them to GTFO yeah and get off our land
right exactly oh all the farmers are
gonna be like no you guys have no
control here
think about those monkeys right okay now
think about what happens in a place like
Manhattan with 2.5 million people when
the food stops coming they're probably
gonna try to leave Jesus Lee yeah you
know hard it is to get the deliveries
into Manhattan it's pretty tough I
didn't know this because multiple don't
drive in my hand but I've driven down
there a couple times like when I moved
out when I moved out of the the city and
onto the Jersey side but almost all of
the streets as far as I could tell maybe
I'm wrong about this but they're like
you can't park during the day it's
commercial only right because it is so
dense the trucks have to come in and
resupply all the stores and make
deliveries so it's almost all commercial
traffic now there's still people who
park but they're parking for their work
and their jobs so you can't just go
there in Park it's it's people don't
realize this the denser it gets the more
trucks have to come in and one of the
craziest things been happening in New
York is Amazon now people who live in
Manhattan are ordering tons of stuff and
it's getting ridiculously congested as
delivery trucks try to come in and you
can't do it man could you imagine what
2.5 million monkeys running around would
be like that now give them now replace
them with in with you know well I want
to say intelligent humans but in the
event of a panic I don't know this
affair will just say humans just say
humans yeah you know humans know how to
use guns and and and weapons and tools
true so you see this these money and
yeah and drive cars you these monkeys
wrestling on the ground for that one
last candy bar yeah now take 2.5 million
humans it's gonna be crazy man III
though people will literally eat each
other
you think it's you think it's a joke man
but and what happened the last plague
that struck the earth vanish flu or Nam
ball in 1920 1918 Spanish 19 yeah people
were eating each other were they really
yeah you know like in like Russia no
that true yeah dude Jordan Peterson
talks about it why in maps of meaning
Wow see that's what I'm talking about I
don't even know that student he shows a
picture of this woman with body parts
and she's selling it for me
dude I would stop a hundred years ago
the less I would starve you you're not
there that's that's actually what he's
talking about he's actually talking
about you don't know what you are
willing to do until you're there now
it's easy to say I would never do that I
would never do it no way never but you
don't know until you're that you know I
hear your bio
no I'm not saying I would eat it I don't
know it's but it's it's tell me about
what you would it's really crazy though
when you when you have this kind of a
situation where there is literally no
food I when I said people are gonna eat
each other and I think that could
potentially happen as a counterpoint
there is a lot of starvation in Africa
and there's not a whole lot to my
knowledge not a whole lot of cannibalism
I know there's that weird tribe that
eats people's brains and I know this
isn't like a plague situation remember
and that guy from CNN ate brain Reza
yeah reza aslan yeah gross I mean the
thought of eating a human I'm vegan that
come on human for anyone she's with a
conscience some bugs man
what cats little birds it was the
weirdest thing to me like you know the
show fear factor yeah yo rubba news that
was - yeah yeah and it was like today to
freak you out we're gonna make you eat
food that's how I always felt when they
were like what is this it's pig
intestine now like I've literally isn't
that like something I've literally think
they'd be like this is the gallbladder
it's like that's literally food talking
about no but what yeah I get it like
obviously the average person is gonna be
freaked out but I'm like y'all need some
discipline man the average American
they're like we want you to eat a
cockroach and I'm like yeah dude most
the world eats this I got no problem
eating food bro yeah I'm an omnivore
just put in front of me and I'll eat it
like look obviously I wouldn't prefer
you would do well on it I would do
really well I'd be like what's this oh
this is bull testicle Rocky Mountain
Oysters they eat that really called yeah
I'm dead serious
I'd be like I am eating animal yeah I
was like you may not know this Joe but I
eat animals every day not not not only
no but but you know why the show got
canceled apparently why because I could
be wrong about the culture no no no look
what can you look this up can you look
up because I want to make sure you it's
right before I say it because it's gross
and people are gonna get mad no I
wouldn't here's right here's what I read
I read they made people drink bull
emissions
very eloquent yeah apparently some dude
did it was like did he win I want that
mic I hope he won for that man that's
crazy cuz I think that that would be the
line for me did he get super buff too
we're serious like white bars where are
we
no but here's the thing they listen less
I love this if you if you gave me a part
of an animal I'm gonna be like bro like
humans exist because we because we
farmed animals we eat things we hunt no
not all of it you know we do we do
hundred we gather or we do we do berries
and fruits I got nothing i got nothing
you give me if he's an imam eyeball
eyeball you you know just you know i
prefer a knife and a fork but sure I'll
I'll take what I can get but emissions
yep
you're right I was right donkey Oh
somehow it makes it worse I don't know
why it was okay that it was a bull way
to read it read it read it read it
audiences had seen it all on fear factor
but one eating challenge hit a new low
for the show when they asked contestants
to drink drumroll please
donkey emission mission mission no I'm a
male spunk stunt leaked before the
episode
audiences were rightly frightfully
disgusted and the network pulled the
episode and
Smyly this show came to an end there you
go
here's the big question you were talking
about what you'd be willing to do no I
will do that now we're talking about
what human oil you royal you well why'd
you look at me like you made eye contact
it was like whoa Adam what would you
drink our apocalypse just kill the
donkey I'd be like no way I'm gonna eat
this are we still talking about people
over buying food you were talking about
the apocalypse panic buying right right
here's the point I'm making you are the
one who brought up what you what would a
person be willing to do if they were
truly starting they have done I think
well first first I want to say a hundred
years ago when the last plague hit
that's what I'm talking about I don't I
want a hundred years right now right I
want to say this first I don't know the
current state of Jordan Peterson I'm not
saying it's a pendant all right I don't
know the card Dave Jordan Peterson I
hope he's doing well oh yeah I hope yeah
I don't know I don't the latest updates
pin you guys you know it all and I don't
know anything about hopefully hopefully
because I would I would love to see him
get better and I would love to have a
legitimate question based on what you
were saying with the flu yeah about
donkey emissions okay oh yeah what would
would people be willing like if you
think they'll eat human do you think
they would do things that are just so
like vile that even fear factor had to
cancel it I mean that's seriously
probably right
I bought eat dirt yeah I think some
people would eat their shoes okay well I
don't know about that there's no
nutrients okay get on the battlefield
and start leather your belt if it's made
of leather you can eat leather you can
like boil it one leg and then the other
man that's a situation cut your own legs
off that's it yeah I said one leg and
then the other I mean what are you
supposed to do like I don't know about
that
I mean but you know what man here's the
thing you don't end up in those
situations if you just take care of
yourself and you're responsible and you
know what you need to get by we're not
gonna this is this is not that we're not
going there we are lucky to live in a
country where we can buy all the stuff
we need and if you don't you're silly
optimism bias right you know what we got
to start doing we got to get rid of
grass we got to get rid of this like
green lawn
is like a status thing she's only had a
card farm yeah I think you're right
grass place our lawns with food yeah
grass food
let's make food yeah right what if
everyone just had like instead of a lawn
care you had a farmer like you know it's
like can you can you call the farm care
company and like come and get these
potatoes harvest harvest the potatoes
first yeah yeah that should be like the
status symbol like whoa did you see
their garden
it is poppin I mean I want them to super
you can't do it in cities like you be
able to yeah and if you live like near
airports there's a lot of just gross
right and whatever mission now I say a
mission mission oh man
okay thanks for checking out this
segment from the Tim cast IRL podcast we
do the show every Monday through Friday
at 8 p.m. sometimes an hour or two and
we do have a full live recorded version
of the show that includes a lot of
comments and smaller segments you
probably don't see if you want to check
that out you can watch live at 8 p.m.
Monday through Friday or become a member
of this channel and for five bucks a
month you get full access to all of the
recorded podcasts every day after the
show we make them available in the
community section of this YouTube
channel so don't forget to subscribe and
stick around for more segments and more
shows Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you